les bosquette avec tout il a ballon
isabelle bleau cheveux alors vrai mais
je veux séparation mais j'ai toujours
invité à des magnifiques cheveux tu
verras la ville en deux phrases sans
point j'étais sûr alors convergé au
monde rien lors de son passage à cannes
en 2018
donc là nabila portait une robe qui a
fait sensation oui car on pouvait voir
le bas de son doux qu'est le tatouage
quelle honte à toi nabila tel à cet
endroit une petite croix sans la chute
des reins par une petite croix attention
une éducation
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
démarche exceptionnelle
cette présentation
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et normalement à côté des marques et
vous êtes dit si vous êtes arrivé c'est
mieux c'est oui c'est du castaldi à
l'habitat c'est nouveau ça tu la fais
juste pour la robe un nom mais parce que
j'avais fait un petit peu ce que
j'aimerais ça mignon j'adore ta d'autres
tatouages
oui mais voilà c'est un pistolet dans le
coup ensuite des ailes d'ange
c'est la date de naissance de ma
grand-mère d'ailleurs que j'embrasse
elle s'est fait mal aux seins elle nous
regarde je t'aime
elle est donc l année en 1900
[Rires]
ces dates genre hyper long et dense et
en blessant 37 et bioware non non non
non et surkiffe pour iphone
ouais non mais moi et elle nous regarde
elle vous adore j'ai fait un gros bisou
oui comment ça va donner mais livia mais
mes lives hier mais je les adore en plus
mal et hyper belle unité rebelle et m'a
très bien aller deuxième question
question bien sûr c'est une question qui
concerne vincent duclos qui était la
partenaire de vincent nick lowe danse
alors de sympathie store de sa
participation à danse avec les stars
dance with the stars to dance et vos
stars hinault le dit aurait donné son
nom sachez petit indice que ce n'était
pas christophe licata dichato allez
c'est fini
c'était quartier à katrina patchett non
c'est trop tard et trop gras cette ferme
alors on sait pas ça ça de ma mère oui
c'était katrina que l'on avait
d'ailleurs reçu il ya quelques mois on
adore mais oui on va revoir une de vos
prestations sur options funk de qui la
maison de roger soubie s'est passé
[Musique]
on peut le voir
by alors skies à la vue la souplesse
designer bisous bravo il va faire un duo
avec mireille mathieu vous allez faire
injure aux aiglons mireille mathieu
s'est elle m'a dit sur vous c'est pas
nous c'est maintenant un allah vous l'a
dit moi je suis beau court elle aimerait
elle aimerait fait rien j'aimerais bien
elle vous adore aller faire un duo avec
vincent nico oui mais il est pas au
courant
comment qu'elle était bien à le suivre
ça c'est quoi le baiia en tout cas il
est d'accord j'adore bamoussa grande
carrière grande dame chez un énorme
donnez-nous mille colombes les ai pas
sur moi après rôle dans la série
la maaf donnez-nous les colons qui
séparait mais avec micro quand j'étais à
cannes on m'a dit que ma robe elle
faisait penser à elle
[Rires]
les gars elle avait le web mais a manqué
ses débuts de chanteuse mais rennes à
nantes est restée exactement elle va
dire que j'ai eu une boule et bill gate
la troisième question aussi une question
allez pour vous ce une question si on
habille la le chanteur sofiane à nom de
reclassement a écrit les chansons sont
d'habiles a calé au titre de cette
magnifique chanson sur nabila fout de
toi
dingue de toi ou je kiffe ton bull bull
non c'est pas ça fout de toi c'est nous
non non c'est quoi c'est d'artois a
regardé mardi
je suis d'
je
habile
[Musique]
je souffre ou deux
alors attention pour l'instant il
s'appelle mon niveau cela qu'un point il
y aura cette question il faut qu'elle
est au dessus de la moyenne section à
ceux d'avril d'aucun des trois bonnes
réponses pour l'instant il reste deux
questions
attention d'isabelle pour quels grands
couturiers
nabila at-elle fait un défilé de haute
couture assises de haute couture oui
alors bah oui c'est qui maze et anja pas
trop positifs tout le monde en a parlé
bah oui mais moi j'ai des trous de
mémoire à mon âge ah oui mais bon alors
gauthier ces enjeux le bottier saveurs
et en tout cas vous entendez au niveau
des actifs alors qu'ils font avec les
mille doit hélas elle émue elle doit
faire elle capte nbc
[Applaudissements]
sereine et oui c'est hurle période
c'était le 2 juillet 2013
vous aviez défilé pour jean-paul
gaultier à l'époque certaines personnes
probablement jalouse temps mais je vous
dis s'était plaint de ce choix 1 les
bien pensants les ronds de cuir vous
êtes une fois de plus magnifique nabil
karoui
[Musique]
elle éveille nabila pour moi moi c'est
une des cinq plus belles femmes que je
connaisse
ah oui vraiment non mais vraiment vous
êtes dans le voyez les photos de vice
vous comme vous étiez belle aussi vous
dit bonjour à la dame jouera pas non
mais oui non mais peuvent voilà à la
dernière question dans quelle série télé
vincent nicolau at il joué ne dit rien
même me souviens pas qu'il va s'agir
maintenant pour le show band 3 200
points
c'était bien sûr sous le soleil x
limites y en avait deux et là on en
extrait de vous dans sous le soleil
et ce jour là il ya dû avoir un problème
de son dirait que vous avez durée
enregistré la scène en fait regardez
vous allez voir on dirait le doublage
d'une série allemande on se sent le
dossier demain je vous annonce était une
série allemande en chaussures laquées
pourquoi changer le soleil c'est de sa
seule série vraiment le coeur en fête et
les serveurs le lendemain sur la tête de
ma mère c'est une opération à coeur
ouvert elle servait d orangina la veille
jean-luc s'apprécie son directeur de
clinique ils ont 20 ans et lola elle est
toujours maillot en train d'opérer un
fini le temps après un original à 17 ans
tu t'es où
je suis allé voir victoria
ça n'a pas marché
mais matt tu veux vraiment pas faire mon
disque je ne peux pas maxime pas sans
l'accord de victoria komova soir j'ai
perdu cette démarche double
quant à elle journal manquant ses neuf
c'est parti très grande et donc ils
voulaient venger le programme en
allemagne at il dit c'est donc moi je
n'ai les répliques groupe français et en
allemand c'était super mais j'étais sûr
j'avais reconnu c'est pas baby pris dans
la bourrasque et à aubin on va rentrer
c'est perdu pour vous ferez alors dans
un instant sur facebook live le
shampoing de nabila et isabelle morini
bosc
on va installer un bac tout ça vous
allez voir ça va être magnifique mais
moi il faut le faire un brushing dans le
vide un galet bas on sera tous à élaguer
papa on a tous les ustensiles du bon
vous vous inquiétez pas ça serait ok ça
paraît c'est rien c'est douloureux bien
sûr mais là et je m'en occuperai
personnel oui mais surtout who